DAVID PAKMAN: We have a voicemail number,
(219) 2-DAVIDP [232-8437].
There's this really unhinged
Anti-Semite who calls in very very often
and we usually don't play his voicemails
for a variety of different reasons.
Here is one that I do want to
play for you just to show you
the type of stuff that we're dealing with on a daily basis.
VOICEMAIL: "Hey, you socialist.
You know, you and AOC should go
back to Argentina where you belong.
You're both a bunch of idiots.
You're the bloody hemorrhoids on a hairy ass [CENSORED].
You socialist.
All you want is votes for the Democrats.
Why don't you go back to Argentina?
Maybe you can wipe your ass there.
With - wait, both your asses; You and AOC."
DAVID: Mmm, no
I'm not a socialist.
I don't know why this keeps coming up,
but I'm just I'm not a socialist
and the idea that - I mean listen,
Alexandria Castro Cortez is Puerto Rican by heritage.
I don't and she's American of course, as all Puerto Ricans are.
I don't know why she would go to Argentina at all necessarily
and certainly I don't know about going back to Argentina,
but this is the type of stuff that day in and
day out we are fighting against and this is why:
you're not going to convince that person to change their vote, right?
Get 10 people to vote who would have stayed home because
it is a waste of time to try to
change the minds of people like that.
Just don't do it; that can't be the strategy for the left in 2020.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I'm out of time to tell you what is on it, but it's a good one.
Become a patron, become a member.
You'll get instant access and I will see you then.